in this video we're going to explore how
we can start with acetic acid how we can
start with acetic acid and acetic acid
looks like this how we can start with
acetic acid and end up with and end up
with a siedel chloride acetyl acetyl
chloride that looks like this
that looks like this and it's going to
be done in the presence of thionyl
chloride and thionyl chloride we haven't
seen it before but it just looks like
this is a sulfur double bonded to an
oxygen and then it has single bonds to
two separate chlorines and then if you
want to care sulfur has six valence
electrons so it has another lone pair
right over here and we'll stay focus on
this because this is really the simplest
the simplest reaction of starting with
the carboxylic acid and forming an acyl
halide and it can be generalized very
easily if you turn this methyl group
into just a larger chain and then this
will be a larger chain right here and
instead of having a chlorine here you
could do it with other halides as well
so let's think about how this might
occur so let's start let's have our
acetic acid right over here so acetic
acid right over here and then you have
this oxygen bonded to a hydrogen bonded
to a hydrogen just like that now this
guy's got two lone pairs
this guy's got two lone players and then
the thionyl chloride I'll redraw the
thionyl chloride right over here
the thionyl chloride and I'll I'll set
it up in the right position the thionyl
chloride looks like this and this has a
this has a lone pair of electrons right
over here and all of these molecules
chlorine and oxygen or all of these
atoms chlorine and oxygen we can look at
a periodic table up here you see sulfur
over here and then to the right of
sulfur is chlorine and above sulfur is
oxygen so both Laurine and oxygen are
more electronegative than sulfur so
sulfur is going to have a is going to
have a partial positive charge there
even though sulfur is a reasonably
electronegative
in its own right but these guys these
other guys are going to be sucking
electrons away from it so you could
imagine that this oxygen could act as or
this entire molecule could act as a
nucleophile with this oxygen right over
here giving an electron to the sulphur
sulphur ziz sulfur as an electronegative
atom but it has a partial positive
charge in just this vinyl chloride so
it'll be attracted there and then this
guy's going to have to give up an
electron and he'll give it back to this
oxygen up there and so that will be and
this reaction could go in either
direction so once again I'll draw it
I'll draw it in equilibrium but right
after that happens we'll have this I
guess we could call it a complex that
would look like this this oxygen it had
two lone pairs it had one pair two pairs
and now it has a third it has a third
pair because it got this electron it
always had that other electron in the
covalent bond and now it has a negative
charge
and now the sulfur is bonded to those
two chlorines two chlorines and then it
is also bonded to this oxygen over here
so let me draw it over here so we have
this oxygen which is bonded to this
carbonyl carbon just like that and then
it is bonded to a hydrogen right over
there it has one lone pair now and then
the other lone pair is now turned into a
covalent bond with the sulfur with the
sulfur and so this guy gave away an
electron so he now has a positive charge
he now has a positive charge
now the next step you could imagine that
this oxygen this oxygen says hey you
know I liked having a double bond with
the sulfur the sulfur the sulfur is
still bonded to a bunch of things that
are more electronegative to it it still
has a slightly positive positive charge
there so you could imagine that this
this electron it gets given back to the
sulfur but then the sulfur needs to bump
an electron chlorine is pretty
electronegative so the chlorine can take
oh one of these chlorines can take will
be able to take away and elect
so this chlorine could take away an
electron so then after that happens our
situation and once again this is an
equilibrium our situation will look like
this let me draw so let me draw the
original acetyl the original acetic acid
or what the part that was part of the
original acetic acid and so you have
this oxygen right over here bonded to a
hydrogen bonded to let me do it in the
same color so we can keep track of
things bonded to that same this sulfur
right over here which now has a double
bond which now again has a double bond
with this oxygen up here other than that
same color it's still bonded to that
chlorine up there still bonded to that
chlorine up over there but now this
chlorine is left it's taken that
electron with it so the chlorine had 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 valence electrons it gained
this electron this orange electron so
now it has it has a negative charge and
by the way this guy never lost his
positive charge still has a positive
charge right like that
now the chlorine could act as a as a
nucleophile on the carbonyl carbon
this guy is bonded to two oxygens more
electronegative slightly or partially
positive charge this guy can give an
electron to the carbonyl carbon and
right as that happens this is a
nucleophilic attack right as that
happens the carbonyl carbon can give up
an electron to the carbonyl oxygen and
then we will be in equilibrium we will
be in equilibrium so make sure you
realize we're going to the right then
down now we're going to the left with
this thing so you have this was the
carbonyl oxygen a carbonyl carbon bonded
to this oxygen right now which now just
took another electron so now it has a
negative charge it had one two lone
pairs now it will have one more lone
pair because it took that electron it
always had this end of that bond so now
it has both of these electrons over here
it has a negative charge it gained
electron and then it is bonded to this
Oh H group right over here this OS group
just like that and then that is bonded
to the sulfur that is bonded to the
sulfur which is bonded to the chlorine
and now double bonded to that other
oxygen and now double bonded to that
other oxygen and of course we have this
chlorine over here that did the
nucleophilic attack so you have this
chlorine over here and it's nucleophilic
attack it gave an electron to what was
this carbonyl carbon it gave an electron
so it is now neutral and you can kind of
imagine that this negative charge got
transferred to this oxygen up here and
this oxygen right here still has a
positive charge
don't don't want to forget that now the
next step that could happen once again
all of these can go in either direction
is that this guy doesn't like having a
negative charge and this guy might is
still going to have a partially positive
charge because he's bonded to a bunch of
electro more electronegative atoms in
itself so he wants to reform the double
bond reforms the double bond and that
kicks off that kicks off all of this
business over here so then this let me
do this in a new color
I've already used the magenta I'll use
the pink this electron right here gets
taken back by this oxygen by this oxygen
that had a positive charge anyway so it
would want to take it back and then we
are left with and then we're left with
and this is this is we're getting pretty
close pretty close to the punchline we
are then in equilibrium this part over
here will then look like this we now
have reformed our double bond it is only
going to be bonded to the chlorine just
like this and this whole part over here
on the right has broken off so you have
this oxygen bonded let me do it in the
same colors you have this oxygen bonded
to a hydrogen it now gained an electron
it now gained an electron so it is now
neutral and it is bonded to this sulfur
letting the sulfur is in green it's
bonded to the sulfur which is bonded to
a chlorine which has a and then it has a
double bond to this oxygen right over
here
so we've already formed we formed our
acetyl chloride we formed our acetyl
acetyl chloride and we've really kind of
finished with the hard part of the
reaction to see that how you could get
an acetyl chloride and then to kind of
complete this reaction because if you
actually perform this in a beaker you'll
end up with some hydrogen chloride and
some some sulfur oxide as a by-product
you could imagine that this oxygen right
over here takes back its electron from
this proton gives it to this sulphur
gives it to this sulphur and then the
sulfur since it got an electron will
allow the electronegative chlorine to
take back its electron to take back its
electron and then if we just focus on
this the acetyl chloride at this point
isn't doing anything anymore this would
be in equilibrium this would be an
equilibrium with something that looks
like this you now have a hydrogen proton
floating around you now have this
hydrogen proton floating around just a
naked proton really there's not even any
neutrons there you have this oxygen
which is now double bonded it is now
double bonded with this sulphur so I'm
going to try to keep all of the colors
the same this right here was yellow and
then that original bond that it had with
it was magenta and then you have the
chlorine nabbed that electron the
chlorine I'll do this chlorine in blue
now the chlorine nabbed an electron and
it already had it already had seven
valence electrons one two three four
five six seven it now has a negative
charge and then the final step so we
already have we already have our sulphur
dioxide
now the fight the final step is just the
chlorine giving one of its electrons to
the hydrogen to form hydrogen chloride
so then the final step is just this is
just this and then we are we end up with
so when all is said and done when all is
said and done we end up with some acetyl
chloride
we end up with some acetyl chloride we
end up with some hydrogen chloride we
end up with some hydrogen chloride and
we end up with some sulphur dioxide
sulphur dioxide just like that and we're
done and once again you can generalize
this to get it starting with any
carboxylic acid and forming the acyl
halide version of it or the acyl
chloride version if you want to stick
with a chloride right over here now I'll
show you this right here is a C till
this is a C til chloride anyway
hopefully you found that entertaining